and carried out now by Anthony duclair chips it
in indirectly around the wall regains possession
couldn't get the shot out cleanly rebound for
grin and tonight nurse was parked to the right
of Skinner and helped keep that out momentum
created a little bit of energy and here's duclair
just undresses Sam g at the blue line and look at
the quality of scoring chance that San Jose gets
right in front of Stuart Skinner a lot of traffic
in front as he deals with this that's something
face offs in all situations and in all zones
that they've faed very well out so far despite
the struggles Aken picked it Aken moving in
short-handed with a backhander and Skinner
makes the stop Skinner has and watched just the
patience of eckan good stick work there and then
he just Shields off mcdavid's back check and look
where he tries to go five hole and you know The
Scouting Report will be for the San Jose Sharks
it'll be thorough and they'll go five hole to
make mistakes even if they happen but the effort
was that one non-negotiable that he said to his
newcomer gunan pulls up on net Skinner makes the
stop shoved into the corner and there's EOL deep
for the Oilers back around McDavid dancing away
from trouble McDavid toward the net and sto by
Blackwood deerland off the shoulder of Skinner
hurdle kept it in in the direction of Eckland and
now hurdle behind the net neet front zland scores
well just nice down low play watch the heads up
play by hurdle he almost looks as if he's going to
put it out to the wing side there and then first
late in the [Music] [Applause] first and the
sharks have the lead on the Oilers approaching
the final minute of the first McDavid from the
corner for a cutting echh home block It Away by
Blackwood Addison right Point moves it for
Hoffman from the line of shot fought off
by Skinner dry cidal outlets and carried
up ice by Darnell nurse nurse two on one
he shoots scores tied at [Applause] one
nice play from Darnell nurse jumping up
in the play supporting Leon dry cidal on
the breakout pass you can see Blackwood
ever so slightly moves too far to his left and
Darnell nurse with his head up the entire way
looks over quickly for the pass potential and
then just puts it Far Side a nice play by the
defenseman and here you can see right from the
middle protecting the golender originally gets
a nice little outet pass from Leon dry can't
escape dry cdle held it in to the line and
bard keeps it on side dry Sidle out high
dry Sidle drops echol shoots Z Blackwood
makes another stop Andy's the Rapp around what
a shift and nice little backpack here you can
see gets an opportunity to wrap it around on
Blackwood just can't elevate it over the pad
but prior to that there was a play in the
neutral zone where he just chips the puck
to Fogle recognizes the sharks are all over him
and it just opened up a huge PCO sturm's been
excellent on faceoffs at 65% wins possession
for the Sharks and now the data turns around
and Dre [Applause] iron ARA and weekie on Deck
with an update from Seattle and Colorado here's
zean nudges it off for okota off of zland
they score Tomas hurdle and the Sharks lead
they had a couple of nice shifts in the
offensive zone and they get some Puck luck
because of it look at the bounce as burls
just throws it towards the goal excuse me
uck does that and it just goes off zland
and right onto the Stick of tomash hurdle
who just patiently comes in on the far
side McLoud spinning at the line moved
across here's Zack he shoots blocked
in front and Blackwood trying to cover
McDavid swatting at it and Blackwood earns a
whistle San Jose loving it here against the
[Music]
Oilers there was traffic parked in front with Zack
Hyman in front of Blackwood McDavid onto the ice
moves it for buar back for McDavid Blackwood
made the stop here's dry CLE wrapping around
save rebound on himman was denied qu looking
up at the jumbo trying to get his highlights
cuz he had a few of them here on this last
shift by the evor they had about four or
five chances look at that left pad save there
on by Heyman and watch this one on McDavid who
hasn't going the other way and he shoots it
back and you can see it just catches the top
of his glove as he looking for an equalizer
there's McDavid on the Hop down the slot he
shoots and Blackwood the stop rebound clued
down by Blackwood on Heyman and a whistle
with 124 to go in the period final minute
of the second zland kicking at it and gets
it back from ecklin Zin trying to escape hurdle
shot turned out by Skinner CC holds it in moves
it for McLoud first couple of minutes of the
third nurse out High spinning away on Carpenter
wedges him to the wall and forces it out to
center now on the Hop here stur with sadena
scor Carell Nur just late in his
shift he tries to make a move and
you can see a nice job by Carpenter
just stays right with him creates the
turnover at the defensive blue line
and sends his teammates on a two
onone and just good quick support by ni
Stern puts it across and no chance for
Stewart Skinner and look at the bench they're
loving it here's Ryan McLoud with a burst eek
of backtracking McLoud short handed to the
net and he draws a penalty on eckan Skinner
out to the bench eckol with it here's McLoud
whips it off to the wing Fogle shoots and a
save Blackwood Puck behind him Bard for newon
Hopkins he holds Bard a blast and Blackwood
the stop your battle to keep the puck in
the offensive zone allows Nan to come out
of the box Nan Hopkins and look at this save
Again by McKenzie Blackwood this was about a
declair dragging it's stood up by a Cole eckol
finishes a check on duclair worked back to the
line here's burrow back around deep duclair
back hand McLoud turns it back for G back
to the line here's Z six on five it's Matias
atol scanning EOL Bard a blast save rebound
score Ryan newon Hopkins makes it a one goal
game with 226 to go he two goals with about two
minutes and 50 seconds left he pulls steuart
Skinner and just look at the traffic in front
and the edmont torers just gets him support
up high a nice little Quick Pass from meom
to Bard he just puts it to net you know there's
nice traffic there kanes there and look at that
104 Point Season last year now McDavid gets
tied up and a penalty coming so the Oilers
will have a power play Down by one Skinner to
the bench Drive Sidle toward the net McDavid
has it kicked out 12 seconds Bard toward the
net width wide McDavid Springs in Kane fights
for it at the half wall back to the line out to
neutral ice and the Sharks take down the Oilers